SANHEIM, FORMER CALGARYPUCK, ON
WING TO GAUDREAU, BACKHAND,  BY
WHISTLED HIGH OFF A ST
THEY GET AN
TKACHUK.
TRIES A SHOT, THAT'S UP
ON THIS POWER PLAY FOR THE
FLAMES.
THE GAMS
OUR FACE-OFF PLAY.
YOU CANOV.
ATKINSON, SHOOTING JUST WIDEDE
DEFENSE AND THEY WANT MORE
CHANCES FROM THE F
GUDBRANSON INTERCEPTS FIRST OF
NO REBOUND
>> Rick: RITCHIE MUSCLED HISBEE.
TOP FIVE IN THE NHL.
THEY WIN THIS, BUT
HERE'S A
PLAYING.
THAT WASN'T THE CASE WHEN HE
ADDRESSED THE MEDIA.
WE NEED INDIVIDUAL
NET, TRICKLED JUST WIDE ON THE
FAR POST, AND UP THE OTHER SIDE
THEIR DEFENCEMEN.
HERE'S TKACHUK, GETS GOODD
ACROSS, STOPPED BY HART!AH HANI.
AND THEN THE1-0TIP IN AND NO CH
HART AS HE HAS TO COME
WIDE!
I THINK HART MIGHT HAVE GOT A
PIPIHERE'S
GOING TO BE A PENALTY HERE.
>> Rick: YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> Cassie: THAT FOURTH TOO.
WHAT A SAVE ON MARKSTROM ON THE
SECOND CHANCE FOR THE AND THIS
BECAUSE GIROUX IS LOOKING OFF T
HART.
FAMILY LIKES HE SPINS
AR 1-0 FLAMES LEAD ON
MONAHAN'S FIRST O
[ Horn ].
[ Cheers and Applause ] CARTER .
HE WAS THINKING LINDHOLM WAS
GOING TO SHOOT AND HE CAN'T  ST
BY MARKSTROM HIS RIGHT
SEEING IF HE CAN HIT TRAVIS
TH N
THE DEFENSIVE ZONE TO START THI.
MARKSTROM FIRST TO MAKE A NICE
SAFEE
WANTED THE FLAMES TO BE BETTER
AT DESPITE THEY'VE WON
SC
SCORES!
[ Horn  THAT HE DIDN'T
PULL HIS GOALTENDER.
I KNOW